r
les commandes à emporter.
Une coopérative montréalaise
a trouvé une solution
à ce problème : offrir
des contenants consignés.
Olivier Bachand.
- Une commande pour emporter
sans une tonne de contenants
qui finissent aux poubelles.
C'est une option qu'on offre
maintenant aux clients dans
ce restaurant asiatique
de Saint-Henri.
ALEX WINNICKI, copropriétaire
du restaurant Satay Brothers
- Essentiellement,
tous les plats qu'on utilisait
du plastique fittent là-dedans.
Tu peux prendre un riz frit,
un plat de nouilles,
une soupe, des pains vapeur...
- Les consommateurs peuvent
repartir à la maison avec
leur repas dans des contenants
en métal consignés
au coût de 9 $ chacun.
- Si tu prends un take-out
à 10 $, tu dois débourser 19
à la place de 10. Au final,
tu reçois ton neuf, ça te coûte
la même chose puis tu peux être
fier de toi d'avoir fait ton
petit effort dans notre grande
lutte pour l'environnement.
- Salut!
- Pour obtenir le remboursement
de la consigne, les clients
doivent rapporter les contenants
dans des points de dépôt situés
à proximité des restaurants
participants, comme
cette épicerie zéro déchet.
Ils sont ensuite amenés
dans un centre de lavage
et, une fois propres, ils sont
redistribués aux restaurateurs.
Le service est offert
par la coopérative Retournzy.
L'idée a germé au début de la
pandémie, quand les restaurants
ont dû fermer leurs salles
à manger et se tourner vers
les repas pour emporter.
CINDY VAUCHER, cofondatrice,
coopérative Retournzy
- On voulait encourager
nos restaurateurs locaux,
mais à quel prix? On créait
une quantité astronomique
de déchets. C'est un peu de là
qu'est née l'idée, en se
disant : Il y a certainement
moyen de les encourager,
nos restaurateurs du quartier,
tout en évitant de remplir
notre poubelle.
- La coopérative a lancé
un projet pilote dans
l'arrondissement du Sud-Ouest
au printemps dernier.
En ce moment, trois restaurants,
un fromager et une épicerie
Metro offrent les contenants
consignés et on compte trois
points de dépôt dans le secteur.
Chez Satay Brothers, le système
est en place depuis environ
un mois; une vingtaine
de clients l'ont utilisé.
- Le plus toffe, c'est
de convaincre quelqu'un
de l'essayer. Une fois qu'ils
l'essayent, bien, tu reçois
ton argent après, ça te coûte
rien. Et je crois que c'est
juste des habitudes à prendre.
- Le consommateur aussi
a un effort à faire dans
cette boucle à rebours,
comme on appelle, la logistique
à rebours, comme on appelle
en économie circulaire.
Plus on aura d'établissements
participants dans le quartier,
plus les consommateurs, on va
dire, participeront, parce que
ce sera rendu juste normal.
- La coopérative,
qui veut étendre ses tentacules
dans Rosemont et Villeray,
s'est récemment lancée
à la conquête du
Plateau-Mont-Royal, où
six établissements offrent
ses contenants consignés.
C'est le cas dans ce restaurant
qui vend aussi du prêt-à-manger.
Le propriétaire, qui avait déjà
mis en place son propre système
de consignes, a aussi adopté
celui de Retournzy.
BILLY GALINDO, comptoir de
prêt-à-manger Billy, j'ai faim!
- Je pense honnêtement
que de plus en plus de
restaurateurs vont s'y mettre.
Il y a quand même un véritable
engouement, je le vois autour
de ma génération, et les jeunes
le sont encore plus. Je suis
assez optimiste là-dessus,
vraiment. Vraiment parce que...
juste dans le quartier, il y a
énormément de zéro déchet,
de vrac.
- Et la réglementation
de la Ville de Montréal
pourrait aider. À compter de
mars prochain, les restaurateurs
ne pourront plus utiliser
certains contenants
de plastique, comme ceux
en polystyrène, pour
y mettre les commandes.
- On espère que, dans
cette démarche de se questionner
ou de se renseigner sur
les alternatives possibles,
bien, le réutilisable soit
une alternative totalement
sensée et qui est considérée.
- Le changement est pas
toujours facile, mais souvent,
il est nécessaire.
- Que les restaurateurs et leurs
clients se le tiennent pour di